well thank you very much everybody a lot
of progress is being made as you see and
we're reopening our country and it's
very exciting and it should have never
happened this plague should never have
happened it could have been stopped but
people chose not to stop it and it's a
very sad thing for the world 184
countries at least but it's a great
honor to have you with us friends of
mine who have been truly great business
leaders and our great business leaders
and you're opening up your company again
to if you think about it thank you
instead of doing a reopening but they're
great companies and they'll do very well
hopefully better than ever before and
that's what we're seeing we're seeing
tremendous pent up demand and it's a
beautiful thing to see so it's wonderful
to have American industry leaders and
that's what you are true leaders to the
White House you've been here before all
of you and we've talked about it in
different times we built the greatest
economy in the history of the world and
nobody even disputes that and one day
they walk in they say so we're gonna
have to close it up until we get rid of
this hidden enemy this this terrible
scourge and that's what we did and we
did the right thing we did an incredible
job we worked with the government's we
work with States all over the country we
had no ventilators are very few from
previous administrations and we came we
became the king of ventilators we have
thousands and thousands of ventilators
we're now helping other countries with
ventilators we had old-fashioned tests
that didn't work they were really
obsolete they didn't work they were
broken and we end up the testing has
been incredible now and to a level that
nobody's seen I got a call from
president moon of South Korea he said
congratulations your testing was just
nobody's ever seen anything like we're
doing we've tested more than all
countries put together
and millions of tests and the highest
quality test but it's it's great to be
with with you we're joined by matt
mattox of wind resorts Chris Reynolds of
Toyota Chris Necedah of Hilton Josh
Bolten of the Business Roundtable
Walt Emmer of Waffle House and thanks to
vice president Mike Pence secretary
Steve minuchin and Secretary Eugene
Scalia that Scalia has very good genes
where Scalia he has very good genes that
guy I'll tell you Scully he's got the
Scalia genes right we all know what that
means
we mourn and I have to say this so
strongly we more in every life
tragically lost to the invisible enemy
and we're heartened that the worst of
the pain and suffering is going to be
behind us we think we really have
crossed a big boundary and much better
days are ahead and I often say I see the
light at the end of the tunnel very
strongly this demand is gonna be
incredible I think next year is going to
be an incredible year for our economy I
think the fourth quarter is going to be
really really good Kevin we were talking
about that before you maybe will say
something and we're gonna be in a
transition quarter next quarter of the
third quarter and I think we'll do very
very nicely there from an economic
standpoint but thanks to the devotion of
the American people the number of new
cases continues to decline the United
States has now conducted nearly 6
million tests far more than any other
nation as I said so many so many tests
and so much has been learned about what
we're fighting and if it does rear up a
little bit in the fall or even a lot
we'll be able to put it out we'll put
out the embers it will put out the
flames two weeks ago we release
guidelines to give States a real strong
indication of what we want and how we
want it done we've really had a good
relationship with the states Mike Pence
has worked very very hard with the task
force he's headed
for so importantly with a great group of
people and it's been it's just been
incredible what's what's taking place
over a very short period of time
including the gowns and all of the
surgical equipment and the safety
equipment and masks people don't talk
about masks anymore that's the other
thing they're not talking about mess
they were talking about where are the
masks because we had a cupboard that was
bare we didn't have a lot of a lot of
equipment or medical supplies in the
cupboard that we inherited now we're
taking in millions and millions of masks
I'll give you a number that you won't
even believe we have an order 500
million masks coming in and we've
delivered millions and millions and tens
of millions of masks all over so you
don't hear about that anymore either you
don't hear about ventilators you don't
hear about masks and you shouldn't be
hearing about testing but that's the
last thing they can complain about I
guess you know if we do if we do two
million tests they said how come you
didn't do three well we do three and
then they say how come you didn't do
four that's like a that's like a dream
for the media but we've done incredible
with the testing and you'll see over the
next coming weeks Mike you may be a want
to speak about that a little bit but
over the next coming weeks you'll see
some some astonishing numbers I don't
know that all of that's even necessary
you have some governor's that love the
tests you have others that like doing it
a different way an old-fashioned way
with some testing but we're going
maximum testing we've encouraged the
more than 30 states that have taken
steps to resume economic activity
already we've given them tremendous
encouragement and support we're backing
them a hundred percent you know many
governors have called me telling me
their plans laying them out governor of
Texas Oklahoma governor of Arkansas many
many governors I spoke with Governor
Cuomo we had a great talk today on a
different subject but he wants to get
open everybody wants to get up and they
want to get open and would I want to get
back to business and their constituents
the citizens of this country want to get
back and that's what's happening so I
just want to perhaps start off by
introducing our vice president and then
we'll go
around the table and you'll introduce
yourself and say a few words to the
media you're covered by your very
serious media out here the audience
can't see it but these are the most
wonderful human beings actually this is
a nice group
I can't imagine we actually have a nice
group of people but Mike if you could
say a few words please I would be great
and then we'll go around the table thank
you
Thank You mr. president and I want to
thank all the distinguished business
leaders who are here in the in the
literally millions of Americans that are
employed at the businesses represented
around this table it's remarkable to
think mr. president before the corona
virus epidemic came ashore we had seen
extraordinary growth in the American
economy not just the stock market
setting records millions of new jobs
more Americans working than ever before
but in January when you stood up the
White House coronavirus task force you
said we had one mission and that was to
save lives and to make sure that that
the health care providers in America
would be able to render the level of
care to any American any American
struggling with the coronavirus that we
would want our own family members to
have and thanks to your leadership
thanks to the partnership that we forged
with states across the country working
with local health officials mr.
president as as you said yesterday we
have light at the end of the tunnel we
really are encouraged by the progress
and even the hot spots around the
country cases are leveling off and in
some areas going down hospitalizations
are declining even in the Greater New
York City area that's a testament to the
American people and to way the American
people now nearly 45 days ago embraced
the guidelines to slow the spread and as
we come to the end of this mitigation
period states across the country have
all embraced those same mitigation and
social distancing efforts the American
people have put them into practice
we've saved lives we've protected the
vulnerable we preserved our health care
system and we're well on our way to
healing our
as you mentioned testing will be a part
of how we move to the next stage it was
just on the 16th that you laid out a
plan for opening up America again and as
we sit here today I'm I'm informed that
35 states have already released formal
opening plans many of which are
consulting directly with our team here
in in the administration and we're going
to continue to work with all of them
testing is a major part of it
and I can assure you mr. president and
the American people that we'll continue
to scale testing across the country
we're doing more than a million tests a
week now 5.8 million tests total we
expect by next month very quickly to be
at a capacity to do more than two
million tests a week we laid out our
blueprint for testing and as I heard
again today on a conference call with
America's governors in agricultural
States there's great enthusiasm for the
blueprint for testing that you unveiled
early this week and will be surging
supplies and resources and reagents into
the States to support that increased
testing but we know that that ultimately
we've we've got to find a way to help
America get back to work and having the
opportunity to hear from these business
leaders about best practices that
businesses are considering whether they
be restaurants like Waffle House or
major corporations and hotels we welcome
that we look forward to partnering with
you as the president said America works
when America is working and we're
absolutely committed as soon as it is
safe and responsible to do so to partner
with governors across the country
partner with businesses across the
country and open up America again so
thank you mr. Prem I cannot just before
we go around Puritan medical supplies a
wonderful company will produce 40
million additional swabs per month
starting in May they've opened up a very
big process and there was funding
authorized by the defense production act
so that'll help the states and again
we're there to help the states a lot of
states can buy their own swabs it's not
that big a deal but we're her
help them we want them to be successful
we had as you know the governor of
Louisiana and today and we told that
story which has been a really great
story and we had the governor of Florida
and yesterday and that was a great story
these were just incredible what's been
happening so maybe we'll start with my
left and Chris you want to take it and
tell them about you I know a lot about
your company but maybe a lot of people
don't tell the story
indeed you do thank you first off for
inviting me back to the White House I
was thinking on the way down here today
I'm based in Washington that I was here
about six weeks ago the world was a
different place we were we were not at
the beginning but we were in the thick
of it fighting this war and we've come a
long way we've made tremendous progress
thanks to your leadership and the
leadership of the administration
there's represented around this table
and otherwise so thank you for that we
you know we are very supportive as an
industry and certainly as a company on
reopening America we think it's critical
that that happened the guidelines that
you and the administration of outlined
we are incredibly supportive of opening
in a safe and healthy way which which
you and vice president Pence just
described we have been trying it Hilton
and as an industry to be part of the
solution throughout so in the middle of
the crux of the crisis when first
responders were unable to get housing
even though our industry and our company
has its share of problems we provided
with American Express 1 million rooms
free of charge to first responders those
rooms are still being provided to first
responders as they fight the war but now
as we think about and I spend my time
predominantly on the reopening of our
business what we realize is that people
do want to get out they want safety they
want to be doing it in a way that is
safe they want to feel good about it but
they want to get out they want to visit
their family their friends their loved
ones they ultimately want to get around
the country and do business again and in
order to do that they want to feel safe
so all the work that you all are doing
is obviously as an administration in the
States is critical what we're trying to
do in our part
is developed the best health and hygiene
standards that exist so when they stay
in our hotels they feel safe so what we
launched just this week was in a
partnership with Lysol one of the most
respected brands with some of the best
scientists on cleanliness and and
killing germs and the Mayo Clinic one of
the most reputable health organizations
in the world we have developed and are
working on the absolute best protocols
that when people come into our hotels
the rooms have been cleaned they've been
sealed the public spaces have have and
that they can feel safe and secure in
that environment so they can get out and
see the people they want to see and see
this great country again like like they
used to we've also been trying to work
with the industry industry to their
credit is trying to mobilize to create a
consistent set of standards so that this
isn't just Hilton the whole industry you
know would would have a set of health
and hygiene standards that would make
that would make people comfortable we
will be sharing it with the
administration sharing it with
governor's already to correct try and
create a standard we stand ready as
Hilton and we stand ready as an industry
to help get America open and moving
again that's great thank you very much
great company and you'll have it up and
running again very soon I know you very
well and you're gonna do a great job
reopening we're reopening Hilton and
we're reopening our nation a lot of
companies are very excited right now
Steve do you want to say just a couple
of words about where we are with the
different things was well I think Thank
You mr. president
mr. vice president it's great to see
these companies here today it's great to
see the reopening I think we're making
an enormous amount to progress yesterday
we met with small businesses that we saw
the benefit of the programs today we're
meeting with big businesses as
particularly pleased to hear from Chris
he's been able to access the capital
markets just the announcement of our
facilities with the Federal Reserve
created liquidity so that public
companies could access the capital
markets and not need to come to the
guard
for support thank you thank you very
much please I'm doing great Thank You
mr. president I'm Walt amber with Waffle
House in Atlanta Georgia it is a it's an
honor to be here today thank you for
including me a a probably a well dressed
cook and dishwasher I don't know about
big companies but but we're happy to be
included and thank you to mr. vice
president for for all of your support I
am here representing our industry I
believe and in large part the
independent restaurant companies of
America that that are out here that have
helped create the fabric of our country
with the restaurants that they've put in
our communities and the connections they
have the communities and and we in a
small way feel like we are a part of
that we did have we did have the
opportunity this week in the state of
Georgia and the state of Tennessee to
open up some of our dining rooms to dine
in customers again and it was very
welcomed by our people it was welcomed
by our customers our customers are ready
to see some sign of progress that we are
beginning to move forward we've done it
in a safe way we have followed all of
the guidelines your guidelines the CDC
guidelines and how to make that happen
but what we believe we when we started
out in this journey we said we really
have several goals and the first goal
was we wanted it to be a safe
environment for our customers and for
our associates and our second goal was
to create financial safety for our
workforce and I wanted to thank you
personally for on behalf of our
workforce for all of the stimulus funds
that have gone directly to the workforce
of America it is making a difference it
has made a difference is keeping the
economic engine turning so ever so
slowly right now but it is helping keep
people put food on the table and a roof
over their head so on behalf of our
workforce I thank you for that as we got
into this we we felt like we needed to
make a lot of adjustments coming in one
of the great things about a
Tron and the entire restaurant community
the restaurants are the second largest
private employer in the country and
there is a million restaurants out there
and probably no other industry has been
hit as hard from a revenue standpoint or
a layoffs and furloughs standpoint but
restaurants if you think about everyone
what's number one health healthcare is
my understanding yeah private employers
I assume you guys are number one overall
but so you know restaurants have a
unique opportunity to help lead us out
of this and and the reason for that in
my opinion is is that we have been
practicing safe food handling for years
the safety of our guests has always been
paramount so what we have done is we've
taken a workforce that is trained to do
that and added more sanitation practices
to it more touch points more social
distancing as as you have prescribed and
the CEC is prescribed and we have a
basically turned our restaurants into
the ability pretty much at half capacity
to to seat yes in our restaurant and
it's given us an opportunity to get the
wheels of the economy our economy our
engine turning a little bit because the
next thing we want to make sure is we
protect the jobs for the people at
workforce and the people in our
industries so we're very appreciative I
did want to say that ever since my
daughter was young she every time she
saw the WH on the TV screen she thought
that that stood for Waffle House so I
don't know if you have the trademark for
the WH or we do but we could probably
work something out for my WH ty for you
this one was here first we might have to
talk then so but thank you for including
us and on behalf of all the restaurant
operators out there in the country we
appreciate this opportunity to begin the
journey to move forward and thank you
very much Walt we appreciate it Chris
Reynolds Chris of Toyota yes mr.
president thank you first for inviting
us Thank You mr. vice president and
giving us an opportunity to share how
Toyota is working within the American
automotive industry to return to work
safely to reopen America safely we
announced on March 18 that we were
suspending production
due to the awful scourge of the
coronavirus on March 19 we started to
plan to reopen we started right away and
just to give you some quick background
on Toyota we've been here in the US for
over 60 years fifteen hundred dealers
1.2 million dollar 1.2 million units of
cars and trucks manufactured last year
four hundred and seventy five thousand
people employed including a great number
in the state of Indiana from where our
Vice President is from going to the next
slide we with that as background really
are trying to apply three fundamental
principles to how we're going to return
to work principle number one is we need
to stay connected with our team members
so every week we conduct phone surveys
with all 32,000 of our factory workers
asking them how are they feeling what's
their health what's their family's
well-being what's their confidence level
in returning to work and we also preview
with them all of the new safety
protocols and processes that we're going
to put in place we share pictures of the
reconfigured factory workplace so they
can have confidence that we're doing
everything possible mr. president to
keep them healthy safe and productive
the second principle that we follow is
that we've prepared our plants and
facilities for safe and healthy working
so like many here we're engaging in
marked off areas that require social
distancing the provision of masks and
face shields where appropriate daily
temperature screening as well as a daily
app based questionnaire that before you
come into work asks you how are you
feeling today do you have any symptoms
so that we can try and manage and
contain the virus and we're using best
practices not only from your own Center
for Disease Control mr. president but
also from around the world to try and
increase the safety and health of our
team members as they produce and then
the third principle is were not date
driven we're data driven so our current
plan is to open on May 11 it'll be a
slow gradual opening of our plants
around the country but we're flexible
every plant will be different we'll have
staggered shifts we'll do many other
things to comply with the Centers for
Disease Control guidelines and our goal
is to prioritize team member and health
mr. president one final point we all
know that our team members live in
communities it's not just the workforce
that they're in they're in communities
so what Toyota has done as its tried to
support the communities in which our
team members live including
manufacturing half-a-million face
shields just since the start of this
crisis to distribute to health care
centers nursing homes first responders
around the country so that our team
members can feel that we're also part of
the community and we've also put
together just released yesterday a
community service announcement aimed at
those communities of color that have
been particularly impacted by the lethal
nature of this virus this announcement
includes celebrities encouraging
everyone to engage in safe practices
promoted by the Centers for Disease
Control so we think it's a holistic
process we think it's also a process
that requires commitment and thank you
for the commitment that your
administration has demonstrated we're
going to get through this as a family
mr. president thank you so Chris what's
Toyota doing in Japan are they open are
they semi open what's happening in Japan
mr. president in Japan the situation
varies Prefecture by Prefecture it
depends on the plant some facilities are
operating some are not and that's really
a function of both the the situation on
the ground in a given Prefecture like
our state or it's a function of demand
so it varies sir
great job you're gonna have a great
Olympics next year too by the way thank
you mr. president really great Olympics
thank you very much
matt mattox please Wynn Wynn Resorts is
thank you mr. president
first I'd like to echo what you're
saying about testing and testing
capacity we have seen a real expansion
in testing capacity in Las Vegas so much
so that our University Hospital is going
from a couple hundred tests today to 10
thousand tests a day they don't have
enough people to test so I signed a deal
with them to allow all Wynn employees to
get tests anytime for free and they're
going to set up on-site testing so
that's moving forward we also during
this time decided to pay all 15,000 of
our employees from housekeeper's to head
of sale
and we did that because I thought that
could help accelerate the economy so as
an example we took our call center and
we've had our call center team up with
the Health District to become contact
tracers we tripled the amount of contact
tracing ability on us for our state to
get that moving and we published a 23
page plan for the whole world to see ten
days ago that lays out exactly what we
think a strip opening would look like we
have thermal cameras at our entrances
we have companies supplied PPE we have
just about every UV technology that you
can think of for disinfectant so we're
ready and I'm encouraging our state that
we need to begin a phased approach and
and get back to business
so Matt when do you think the Las Vegas
Strip will be opening you have any idea
so the plan that I put forward to the
state is this week let's start phase one
Golf Course tennis courts small
restaurant small retails nail salons etc
with social distancing in place judge
the benchmarks that we've prepared we
prepared three benchmarks based on
disease growth ICU capacity and testing
positivity rate we're gonna have them
out there public every day if we're
inside those benchmarks in three weeks
then on Memorial Day I would hope that
we're open and you have a lot of excess
testing capacity that's great we do
others have said that - we do rob Santa
said it yes so all 12,000 of our
employees in Las Vegas can now go get a
test that's fantastic thank you very
much great job say hello to all of my
friends I will I will of course
Josh Bolten please business round table
and does a great job at the business
round table thank you Jewish Thank You
mr. president thanks for this
opportunity
I'm Josh Bolten I'm CEO of the Business
Roundtable and organization of nearly
200 of America's leading CEOs who
collectively employ over 15 million
people every sector of the economy is
represented in our organizations so we
have an opportunity to get a view of the
big picture and mr. president we we
don't need to tell you that right
now the big picture is very challenging
we were facing the largest economic
crisis in certainly an hour in our
lifetimes and and all of our members are
keenly aware of that we think now is the
moment that it's critical that the
countries start getting back to business
as rapidly as possible not just for the
health of the economy but for the health
and well-being of all of our citizens in
our country successful reopening will
depend as as the the other panelists
have said on a lot of different elements
and if I may I'd like to highlight three
top of the list is safety first
Business Roundtable companies are all
uniformly committed above all to
protecting the lives and the well-being
of their employees and their customers
and that means following sound public
health guidance like the one like the
guidance that has issued here from from
the very capable people on your team at
Business Roundtable all of our members
either already have in place or are
formulating careful plans for
responsibly transitioning back to work
like the plans we've we've heard about
just now this afternoon they're devising
new measures around personal protective
equipment cleaning procedures virus
screening ongoing social distancing in
the workplace or all of the things that
you know about and they all seem to be
excellent plans which takes me to my
second point which is consistent
guidelines no matter how good every
company's transition plan is then we've
heard a lot of good ones here this
afternoon public confidence will be
undermined and the speed of the
reopening will be dramatically slowed if
we're all doing different things and
that's why the Business Roundtable has
called for clear science-based guidance
from the federal and state governments
on appropriate safety measures in
multiple workplace and commercial
settings at different stages in the
progression of the disease the White
House guidelines mr. president that you
highlighted in your first slide the ones
that came out too
weeks ago are an excellent start in
identifying a common set of phases for
dealing with reopening and a number of
states are off to really good start in
identifying recommended safety measures
in each of various different settings
now we think since we are now on the
cusp of many places being ready to
reopen more fully we think more specific
guidance is needed and so on Friday we
sent to the vice-president and to all
the governor's a set of recommendations
on the kinds of consistent guidance our
businesses feel is necessary for the
safest and fastest reopening and we're
grateful for the chance to engage with
the vice president's team and all of
your task force on those issues and I
should say mr. vice president that
everybody in your administration despite
heavy burdens on them has been very
receptive to taking advice from the
business community and we're very
grateful for that
final point ample testing and monitoring
the only thing worse than an
unnecessarily slow recovery is a
reversed recovery so to avoid serious
setbacks as our businesses reopen
we need to stay vigilant identifying
rapidly and identifying rapidly and
isolating new kovat cases and carefully
tracking the spread of the disease as I
know your team is working very hard on
the robust testing and other forms of
monitoring are the keys to the vigilance
and they'll also teach us what's working
and what's not working and allow us to
make adjustments it'll take a while for
our economy to return to normal but the
traditional American virtues of
vigilance adaptation and innovation
we're confident will see us through and
get to get us to the other side of this
crisis as safely and rapidly as possible
Thank You mr. president for thank you
very much Josh
the numbers when you look at the stock
market today the enthusiasm is great
it's up for substantially as you know
and I think people are seeing a very big
year coming up next year and I think
they're seeing a very big fourth quarter
Larry would you like to say Larry Kudlow
a few words please just a few words
thanks to everybody mr. president mr.
vice president and all the business
folks and my friends to munition this is
a tough one
I've been around a while this is a tough
one and the contractions gonna go on for
a bit but I like what I hear around the
table and I agree with the president we
will see a growing recovering economy by
summertime and the back ends of the year
and it's gonna extend into 2021 that's
what I think's got to happen and I think
the stock market is signaling some of
that I wanted to buck it over to my dear
friend and colleague Kevin Hassett he he
gave it to me over in the Oval yesterday
I want to send it over to him today but
I appreciate it mr. president thank you
sir Thank You Larry and mr. president
mr. vice president I think when I first
came back back in early March that it
was clear that you had a first objective
with respect to the economy of building
a bridge to the next Shore the other
shore when we could restart the economy
and it was really massive fiscal action
that made it so that a day like today
could be possible where as you look
around there are all these businesses
that have the wherewithal to startup and
it's because they've stayed connected to
their employees the checks that we've
mailed to citizens means that they're
going to be demand for their products
and so the the big negative numbers that
we're going to be seeing over the next
few months don't necessarily mean what
they would have meant absent all those
policies and so I think that that we all
have a great deal of optimism about how
quickly the economy can come back and
it's precisely because of what we see in
the room today that people are have come
up with plans based on the guidance that
your task force mr. Vyse
president have given that make it so
that they can operate safely and they're
gradually across the country opening up
and getting back to work and they're
able to do so because of the lifeline
that you mr. president through them with
all the first three phases of fiscal
policy thank you
and it's great to have you back too
very talented guy at least he made a lot
of good predictions your predictions
alternate between you and Larry that's a
it's a tremendous team thank you both
very much
jean secretary a very important thing
called labor that's more important than
labor well it is so important and mr.
president was pleased to be able to tell
you earlier today that as of yesterday
all 50 states and the District of
Columbia are now offering the additional
$600 and unemployment insurance that was
part of the cares Act that you signed
last month this was an additional
benefit on top of what the states we're
already making available in unemployment
and one important part of your program
to support workers during this difficult
time
as you know that the states have had
some challenges with their computer
systems we've been working with them
this is not declaring victory on all
aspects of delivering those unemployment
benefits but it is a milestone I wanted
to note I would have been very pleased
to hear the discussion among this group
about all the steps that companies are
taking to keep their workers safe I
think we all appreciate that confidence
in the part of workers that they will be
safe in the workplace is going to be an
important part of the reopening as well
as confidence in the part of business
about what needs to be done and that
when those steps are taken they will
have satisfied their obligations we at
the Labor Department have been working
carefully in conjunction with the CDC to
provide guidance for a variety of
different workplaces so that employers
and companies know what needs to be done
and employees know as well and and we'll
continue to do that
we're also receiving complaints from
workers who worried about safe work
conditions or that they might have
experienced some adverse action for
raising safety concerns and and we'll
look into those and will we have
tools that we need from an enforcement
perspective if workers rights aren't
respected but I'm so heartened to hear
the steps that businesses want to take
and are taking to support their workers
just just a last observation mr.
president as you and the vice president
said just just weeks ago we are enjoying
such an extraordinary economy and and
and there were reasons for that there
were policies that you put in place
lower taxes deregulation that were vital
to what we enjoyed before right now
we're in a period of very important
government intervention we need that but
as we look forward to the department I
think it will be important to remember
as well the limits of government and
that the single best thing for workers
is a vibrant economy and that often
comes from allowing free markets and
free people to go about their business
we'll keep that in mind - thank you okay
any questions for our panelists this
could be a question for for any of the
business leaders but there are polls
that show that Americans say the vast
majority of Americans say that once
they're allowed to go back to
restaurants hotels places like that but
they won't because they don't feel safe
so do you are you worried that until
there is a vaccine people really won't
come back to some of these businesses
we're talking to our customers last year
we served 180 million people so we have
a pretty pretty big an extensive
customer base what what we're hearing
from our customers is that they're
desperate to get back out and and move
around and see their country again and
see their friends again they obviously
want to do it in a safe and healthy way
and so I think they're looking our
customers are saying they're looking for
for the government both state and
federal government to focus on testing
so that they understand you know what
real mortality rates are as work has
been done with the Stanford test and the
you know the data in Norway and other
data points that are coming out as the
administration and states do more and
more testing I think our customers what
I'm hearing from our customers they're
starting to understand while
every life is precious that the reality
of the ultimate mortality rates here is
probably much much lower than had been
estimated and if they are old and and
infirm that they have great risk and
those people should be protected but if
they're not they probably are at a very
low risk they're then looking for which
is why we launched this week clean stay
and while we're working with our
industry they want to know that people
are being responsible right they want to
know that that we are doing the testing
the the the social distancing that we
are using protocols and PPE in
protecting our employees so that they
can protect customers that we're being
very thoughtful and sensible that when
they do come and stay with us or they
enter into a restaurant where we've
always had good hygiene as you heard
earlier we we are you know our people
are trained to have good hygiene but we
up our game so so that when they're with
us they feel safe so I think it's a
combination of those things that are
happening of broadly understanding the
real risk that they have and then
mitigating that risk even further by the
specific actions that we all take in our
places of work with our team members and
and thus ultimately with our customers
well I haven't seen that I will tell you
to me I think there's a tremendous
pent-up demand for people I see it in
Texas where they have lines going into
stores and a couple of restaurants I
guess opened and there they're literally
have they have long lines I think
there's a tremendous pent-up demand I've
been to the White House now for many
months and I'd like to get out as much
as I love this is the most beautiful
house in the world in my opinion but I
think there's just a great demand to get
out and you know get our country going
again and that includes going to
restaurants and hotels and I think
you're gonna find Chris that you're
gonna have to a lot of business that
you're not even thinking about I'm
seeing it I feel it and I've felt a lot
of things over the years including gee I
think I can win for president you know
and frankly I really feel that next year
is gonna be a very good year
economically we're gonna be back in
business so we'll have to see I mean
only time will tell but there's a lot of
good feelings and a lot of good
decisions have been made by a lot of
very talented people so I'm feeling very
much that it's going to be very
successful mr. president do you want the
FDA to issue an emergency youth Austin
emergency use authorization for in
desert ear well it's a big it's a big
thing what happened just recently where
they came up with something that has a
very substantial percentage you know
it's a building block Tony said it today
I thought it was very well expressed he
said that's a building block that means
it's a very substantial chunk of a step
and that's a building block to the
ultimate step that's a big building
block when you hear I guess 31 percent
so it was very good yeah I want them to
go as quickly as they can
Steven Hahn dr. Hahn has been incredible
at the FDA he's getting things done at
record time there's never been anything
like it and yeah we want it we want
everything to be safe but we do we would
like to see very quick approvals
especially with things at work Thank You
mr. president
mr. Baldwin and others suggested that
they'd like to see federal guidelines
for some of these companies explicit
federal guidelines listing these
companies and factories opening back up
so far you've given a lot of discretion
to companies in states but is that
somewhere where you'd be willing to step
in and do more
well we'll step in if we see something
wrong we have given discretion to the
governor's have become very well
acquainted with the governor's you have
some very talented governor's frankly
and probably some that are a little bit
less talented that's okay but it's a
very talented group of people and
they're working with us we're helping
them whether it's ventilators or swabs
that they can't get we're there and
we've taken in billions and billions of
dollars worth of equipment and
distributed to the states and you know
you you've heard the calls and we have
no problems
we're doing really well and we're
backing them up but we want the
governor's to call those shots if we see
something that we don't like or that's
bad or that's unsafe we'll stop it
immediately okay Mike the new normal
three years from now say restaurant
workers hotel workers might they be
required to wear masks that sort of
thing what would the not was three
months ago
I think we want to go back to where it
was I've been when I look at a baseball
game I want to see people right next to
each other I don't want to see four
seats in between every person so that
the state it becomes 25% of its original
size no I want to see the NFL with a
packed house I don't want to see NFL
with three seats in between people no I
want to I want to go back to where it
was that's what we're going to be look
this thing will pass and when it passes
that'll be a great achievement and we
we've done a very good job
it's far too many people needlessly
because it could have been stopped at
the point of origin and somehow we
weren't helped by whether its World
Health Organization or China whoever we
weren't they didn't do what should have
been done first said actually for the
whole world that's a very sad thing it
was a very very sad event to war against
the invisible enemy and and we're now on
the other side and we're I think what I
want to see is I want to see where it
was and I think we have a chance have an
incredible year next year
now not if somebody's going to come in
like our opponents and raise taxes all
over the place it will raise taxes
that's that will kill something very
fast we have something that's very
special
we built the greatest economy in the
world and I want to get that back as
soon as possible I think we can start
getting it back very very quickly look
at the stock market today when it has
that kind of Kevin and Larry what it has
that kind of Josh wonder that's that
kind of a bounce today as much as it
went up but I think it said some kind
almost a record over the last week right
it's almost a record and this is in the
midst of something now we're not in the
midst they feel worth the other side of
it or you wouldn't be seeing numbers
like this but so we're at 24,000 maybe
even a little above 24,000 and we were
29,000 we never broke 30 on the Dow so
that's tremendous but what it really
does you have a lot of our support
people that means that they are looking
to the future
number one and I look at it as jobs I
also look at it as sort of guidance it's
a guidance in a sense it's the stock
market who would think you could have a
stock market at 24,000 after we've gone
through the worst pandemic since 1917
that's over a hundred years you know is
the worst since 1917 so I think that's a
great indicator there's a lot of very
smart people that understand that world
very well and they have a lot of
confidence in it and that's some of the
companies that we hear public companies
but it means jobs
it also means not only guidance it means
some really some people and I know some
great investors people really have a lot
of confidence in what's going forward
and that's what I see and that's where I
want it to be okay mr. president are you
open to making a deal with the Postal
Service that would allow it to borrow
from Treasury without raising its
shipping rates it's a package we have to
raise the rates on packages because
they're losing a fortune on packages
they're losing anywhere from $2 to 3 or
4 dollars a package every time they
deliver so it's not fair and it's not
fair to the people that work at the
Postal Service you have some of these
companies the internet retail you look
at that and they drop millions of
packages or the post office the post
office delivers a package and every time
they look they deliver a package they
lose from two to five dollars a package
and what kind of a business is that and
you could never replicate the post
office the post office is massive but
they've got places in little sections of
our country that no company could ever
go to that took hundreds of years to
build the post office and when you look
at the size of it and you compare it to
companies it's much bigger than
companies I mean much much bigger
there's no company that's the size of
that no we want to stabilize the post
office and the way you do that is these
companies are going to have to pay more
not the people we're not looking for the
people but the companies are going to
have to pay a percentage of that that
lost you can't do that government
shouldn't have to do it I think the post
office could wouldn't it be great if it
could after so many decades break even
but we're making a lot of people rich
and a lot of companies rich by
subsidizing these companies on top of
that they don't pay the same taxes as a
retail store it's very unfair to the
retailers you look at these stores the
retail stores are being just clobbered
and there are so many disadvantages but
no when we deliver a package at the post
office every package it delivers they
lose a lot of money and that's not fair
those companies should pay for it Steve
a president over a year ago asked us to
chair a postal task force to look at
restructuring a year ago we didn't have
any board of governors we now have a
board of governors that's overseeing it
they're conducting a search we look
forward to hearing the results of the
new postmaster and we think this is a a
business and the people at the post
office will have a terrific opportunity
and we're protecting our post office by
the way and we always will but we want
our post office to be successful we
don't want it to be a laughing stock and
a stupidly run organization the way it's
been for so many decades now it's
ridiculous and then we make other people
rich
we make other people rich because we're
willing to deliver packages at a
fraction of the cost so other people
gain by it and by the way and you're
hurting a lot of other people because
you're hurting retailers you look at
stores where the stores are they have to
pay rent and taxes and all sorts of
things that these companies don't have
to pay so it's it's not a fair situation
we want to take care of our taxpayers
that we want to take care of very very
importantly the people that work at the
post office yes please mr. president if
there is another round of aid for the
states in communities are you going to
try to restrict that aid from going to
sanctuary cities and states I don't
think you should have sanctuary cities
if they get that kind of aid you know if
you're gonna get aid to the cities and
states and for the kind of numbers
you're talking about billions of dollars
I don't think you should have sanctuary
cities and by the way the people that
have sanctuary cities they don't like it
I think politicians like it a lot more I
go to California I go to lots of
different places and I have people with
a very liberal bent saying they don't
like sanctuary cities they don't want
criminals to be in sanctuary they want
they want they want security they want
safety and you know they want borders
too they don't want people pouring a
cross into our country and you know I
was there a long time ago the wall is is
up to 175 miles built down and and it's
the numbers are incredibly good because
all of that hundred and seventy-five
miles nobody comes through nobody even
comes close to coming through unless you
say climb or not the first but even they
don't it's not even easy for them Josh
so it's it's been good but we let very
important for you we want our farmers to
be able to get to help and we work it so
it's actually easier for them to get in
you know they've been taking some people
that they've had for years and years
that come with the crops and everything
else and that really have been great for
the farmers and we want that to continue
and actually continue at an easier pace
we're working it so it comes in so so
that kind of help can come in even
easier which I think you have to tell
you people
is explicitly what you seek to prevent
the next round of eight from going to
sanctuary states and cities well number
one we shouldn't have to pay anything
anyway because all they do is make it
very hard for law enforcement so that's
number one but I think in the bigger
picture I don't see helping cities and
states if they're going to be sanctuary
because all sanctuary means to me is
it's protecting a lot of criminals and
and others many people but they are
there are criminals and you know you
write about it all the time I see
stories every day where somebody's being
totally protected
ice can't get to law enforcement can't
get to them you look at law enforcement
law enforcement hate sanctuary cities we
want a safe country we don't want people
that are criminals and criminals from
other countries in many cases protected
and you can't get to me that was
supposed to make massive payments to
those states to bail out what they've
done wrong over a 25-year period so
we'll see that'll be a subject that will
be discussed certainly sanctuary cities
I think maybe was brought up yesterday
and I made the statement of people were
surprised to hear it but they shouldn't
be surprised okay thank you president
what would you like the country to fully
be reopened to the way it was before as
you mentioned very strongly Josh
mentioned safety have to have safety but
at the same time people want this
country open the people here want it
open and there is a danger to too much
being confined to a house or an
apartment to wherever you Olivia you
can't it just we got to start moving
along and with all of the testing we're
doing with all of the things we're doing
you can do this now and and governors
are actually a lot of pressures being
put on governors right now by the people
in their states they want to get it open
and that's what you want that's what we
all want and with all of the procedures
and safety we've learned a lot about
this hidden enemy we've learned a lot
and there'll be pockets of fire and
we'll put them out we'll put them out
very very quickly but you know during
this period of time
I think we've really learned a
tremendous amount about how to handle it
nothing easy but we want safety so we
want safety and we want economic where
people can go and make a great living
and go back to living the way I mean you
had people we had wonderful people in
yesterday where the business was going
to be lost other than what we did Steve
with the great programs that we set up
their businesses were gone one man he
was a chef with five children and his
mother lived with him and his wife and
he got he lost his job for the first
time in his life some of you were there
and and you had others that were equally
so pretty pretty amazing I thought it
was a pretty amazing display of what
we've done to help a lot of people and
you have millions of people like that
millions that have been helped where
they wouldn't have a job right now and
where the business the small business
would have closed now these are big
businesses but the small businesses
would have closed and I think it's great
when when win which is a terrific group
of people but when Matt says that you
know we're supporting all of the people
I know what that is that's a big you
have all you practically a full staff
and you have no income that's a big
thing that's a great thing I hope you're
rewarded for that thank you thank you
very much that's a tremendous thing as
as soon as possible some states are
already open I mean they were opening up
rapidly we have a number of um opening
up on Monday we have a number of them
opening up sooner than that as you know
and or at least partially opening some
of them even very even with a very
strong bent toward opening they're
opening up with a lope at a certain
amount here restaurants at 25% then
going to 50% then ultimately we want to
be back to where the we're a hundred
percent we don't want we at one
restaurant don't to come up to me and
said sir you know I'm going to be
opening up but if I distance too much I
have 50 percent of the restaurant I had
I said and you'll also have a worse
atmosphere we want to be back where we
can have we want it to be the way it was
because the way it was is the right way
we can't have somebody with a half a
restaurant do you understand again 175
seats now he's got half
that's not gonna pay the rent or
whatever same thing with an owner I was
on the phone with the commissioners and
some of the owners of sports of of
big-time sports and he was talking
almost like he was gonna have two or
three seats in between everybody that
was there and I said you know you're not
gonna have to do that for that long you
know it's you're gonna be back he said
really oh really it was like I don't
want people to get used to this because
this virus is going to be gone and when
it's gone you want to get back to normal
you're not gonna have a stadium that's
thirty percent the size of what it was
three months ago if i watch alabama play
LSU I don't want to see 20,000 people
instead of a hundred and twenty thousand
people we want it to be the way it was
now we've got to wait till it's gone and
it will be gone and we've done a lot to
get rid of it but we we want to open our
country the people want this country
open so a lot of progress is being made
on a vaccine but you never know right
you never know you know with SARS they
didn't come up with a vaccine and
sometimes they don't and sometimes they
do I will say this I don't think there
was the same effort because a lot of
people don't know what's ours is and
some people do but but they do come up
with vaccines I mean you look at what's
happened as an example with Ebola with
AIDS with others that have been so
incredibly successfully if not
eradicated certainly it's been
incredible what some have built with
with what these people that I'm dealing
with right now like Gilead today with
you know what they came up with is an
example that's far ahead of schedule so
we're looking for vaccines were looking
for therapeutics also I mean I think
therapeutics right now I'd rather if you
gave me both I'd rather have to serve
because that you know makes people
better right now whether it's helping
them along or makes them better almost
instantly we have to see
but there's tremendous work on
therapeutics going on and I think we're
having some good results one of them was
was Gilead today a lot of a sudden the
full restaurants the stages
theoretically could come I think I hope
that's gonna happen Johnson & Johnson
Oxford you know you hear a lot of very
good stories I'm hearing a really
first-hand good stories very promising
but they have to test it you know maybe
it's not safe maybe it eradicate sit but
it's not safe and you know they have to
do testing with vaccines where's the
therapeutics it's it goes a lot quicker
in terms of the process know if you
don't have a vaccine if the virus is
gone we're like we were before but
having a vaccine would be a great thing
and I think we're gonna get there in
this case just based on what I know but
we'll see what happens look the the
Gilead research has been I mean that's
gone so fast that's gone at a level of
speed that nobody's ever seen before and
that's a stepping stone so I think
they're doing very well but no I want to
get I want to get back with or without
but I want you know obviously we have to
wait till it's gone it will be gone and
we want to be back to where we were yes
without a vaccine sir why do you think
the virus will just be gone it's gonna
be eradicated and it might take longer
it might be in smaller sections it'll be
it won't be what we had and and we also
learned a lot again if you have a
flare-up in a certain area if you have a
I call them burning embers boom we put
it out we know how to put it out now but
we put it out and now we're equipped now
we have more ventilators than anyone
thought was possible I mean we're doing
a tremendous service for the world right
now we're giving ventilators you know we
have we're making hundreds of thousands
of ventilators in I believe nine
different plants that made other
products in some cases cars in some
places other things these companies
General Motors and and Ford in another
way and
and GE so many companies have Honeywell
they've stepped up thorium has been
terrific they've stepped up like
nobody's ever seen before
and the job they're doing is great and
I'll tell you I think the job that
they're doing on vaccines and on
therapeutics has been great too
we'll see I mean we'll let you know
about that in a little while please
today firstly on reports that the
Treasury secretary and others may have
depends on plates but it's about $25 but
on the suggestion the Treasury secretary
and others made presented you with a
plan for government assistance to get in
trouble it's not their fault that they
got hit by 50% less volume in one day
you know one one instant - all of a
sudden these very great companies are
employing all these people so I'm
talking to Steve and you know what we
just saved the airlines the airlines
were having the best year they've ever
had and then all of a sudden they're
like out of business we can't let that
happen so we saved the airlines that's
done we're saving other companies and
industries and I would say Steve maybe
you can talk to it but I think the oil
industry is one of the top on the list
so we're looking at a lot of different
strategies we have a dedicated team
combined of people at Treasury and
people at the Department of Energy as
I've said before this is not going to be
a bailout of shareholders but this is
going to be supporting the national
security issue I would just comment the
Secretary of Energy has done an
extraordinary job of taking in oil in
the strategic reserve and being paid for
the storage capacity in oil we're also
exploring potentially having the ability
to store another several hundred million
barrels so we're looking at lots of
different options were in touch with
lots of people around the world and the
president is determined that we protect
the national security interest and the
jobs
this week about we had a very
interesting thing because we had a lot
of capacity meaning you can fill it up
in the national strategic reserves and
you know wasn't full and we made a great
deal if you would have told us that we
could have had that filled up or it's on
the way to being filled up at the kind
of pricing that we're talking about I
would have said you have to be kidding
we're talking about 19 I'm not sure
Krista's gonna be happy about this
because it doesn't pertain to the hotel
business don't get scared but you know
we're talking about like 1952 pricing
it's it's unbelievable its prices that
are so low and in some cases we're
storing oil and getting paid for storage
because we have a tremendous capacity
for it so what's happened with the
strategic reserves is incredible you
know it's this weaker do you have a
timeline for that say additionally it
might be announced this week or you have
a timeline for it one that right now
we're dealing with some of the big ones
but where the big ones are very strong
they've been very strong over the years
I think that they're not going to have
the problem but we have a lot of great
people and a lot of great jobs in Texas
and Oklahoma and North Dakota and other
states that are great its energies now I
don't even call it oil I call it energy
this is this is the backbone of of the
world really you know you can talk all
of the green I'm all for green but the
green can't power these massive
factories that are being built in this
country
it just can't the windmills aren't going
to be able to do it and solar is not
going to be able to do it I love solar
but it's not going to be able to do it
and you know we're getting it for the
right price but we're not going to let
our we're energy-independent we're not
going to let our energy industry down
we're not going to let them and it's not
our fault it's not their fault
but we're not going to let anything
happen to them so we're working on that
very hard I think protecting energy and
energy independence to me that's
a very big part of what happened you
know we it energy has really helped to
me turn this country into the economic
power that it's been and we're not going
to let that go unsure it's going to have
a couple of bad years we have a
tremendous oversupply the reason we have
the oversupply though number one it was
a very efficient business and but the
reason we have it is because the demand
got cut in half one day by this by this
plague one day all of a sudden take a
look at the roads it goes from packed
highways everybody traveling going all
over to no cars on the road I mean that
was 25-30 percent right there but then
there's other things factories that
aren't working right now because of this
we did a great thing last night using
the powers that we have to make sure
that the processes and and all of the
delivery of our food chain that it was
protected and safe and those people we
were on the phone with all of them this
morning pretty much all of them as you
probably know they were cheering
literally cheering over the phone we did
some good moves not moves not money move
so much as as common sense modes because
they were being you know they were being
hurt by stupidity and we have them
really back online so I think we put out
that's called burning embers too we put
out a fire so there'll be plenty of meat
and pork and everything that you want
yeah
and mr. president you said you were
anxious to get out of the White House
man we see some travel in the next week
or so I think so I think I'm going to
Arizona next week and we look forward to
that and I'm going to I hope oh hi oh
very soon and we're going to start to
move around and hopefully in the not too
distant future we'll have some massive
rallies and people will be sitting next
to each other I can't imagine a rally
where you have every fourth seat full
every every six seats are empty for
every one that you have full that
wouldn't look too good no I look I hope
that we're going to be able to do some
good old-fashioned 25,000 person rallies
wherever
was going a while because they love our
country okay fact that to happen well
I'm going to Arizona and that's a little
bit different that's having to do with
industry because it's too soon for you
know for the big for the big everybody
get together and stand next to each
other crowds but that'll be next week
it'll depend it also depends on States
you know you have different states some
states are really in great shape now and
some states will be in great shape but a
lot of progress has been made a lot of
progress has been made it's pretty
incredible even if you look in New York
I spoke with Governor Cuomo at length
today and you know they were on that
other side of the curve a lot less it's
been hit very hard you know it's it's
New York and you probably would expect
that but they're on the other side of
that curve the the bed usage and the
people coming to hospitals is way down
much lower than it was so a lot of very
positive signs are happening okay so
presidency effect to be able to hold
rallies before the elections oh I hope
so
tremendous pent up demand they love what
we're doing and they don't want to have
taxes raised they don't want to have
stupid things happening they like the
trade deals we've made great trade deals
I mean the greatest trade deals ever
made in this country and that's what
they want and we have a lot of them that
were lined up and ready to be done right
Kevin we have deals that were lined up
with countries ready to be done that was
so good for our country so good for our
workers and then this scourge came along
and you know that's the last thing
people are thinking about right now it's
you know we put them on hold for a
little while but but now I hope to have
I hope to see football games and
baseball games and basketball now about
for basketball you're gonna have to have
a little bit of a time I don't know what
they're gonna do maybe they'll be able
to play sort of toward the finals or the
playoffs or whatever they're doing
I suppose doing something very unusual I
don't know I don't know if I agree with
it I'd like to see the Yankees played
Yankee Stadium I see they have some
ideas for baseball that are very
different I guess I'm a traditionalist
but I think they'd be able to play at
Yankees
with obviously smaller crowds and then
the crowds would start to build as
things get to be a little bit better but
no I think you're gonna see some some
big things happening and again this is
going away this is going away I think
we're going to come up with vaccines and
all but this is going away and when it's
gone we're gonna be doing a lot of
things and again you have to look other
areas there are areas you know we all
look at New York and we see New York and
New Jersey and some of these very
high-density places where they're doing
a very good job it's just you know it's
not easy but you have areas that are
really at a very low point and and
really heading I always say heading
south quickly and that's what we want so
we'll see how it all works out I think
it's working very good how about one
more just on that point of this going
away not to belabor the point but isn't
it going away because people are staying
in their homes and people are not
traveling and once they go back out
there's no evidence that it would go
away I cannot tell you how dedicated the
people of this country have been in
terms of that yeah you know one thing of
you staying home you're not catching it
if you stay in your place and you don't
go out and you know which is what people
were doing but they want to go out now
they want to get back and they want to
do what they have to do and some of the
facts are coming out and we did all the
right moves that's how we did we
wouldn't do we're talking to Mike before
if we didn't do what we did you would
have had a million people die maybe more
maybe two million people die and if you
think that would be at 65 or 70 or 60 or
whatever the final number will be it one
is too many I would say it one is far
too many this should have never been
allowed to happen should have been
stopped a long time ago before it ever
got here or to other countries but if
you really think about it you could have
had I take a look at Elmer's hospital or
take a look at some of these places that
I know growing up in Queens and I know
Elmhurst Hospital I know these places
very
like the back of my hand and you see
body bags lying all over the hallways
and outside and going into refrigerated
trucks and multiply that number by 10 or
20 if we didn't do what we did it
wouldn't be acceptable it wouldn't be
sustainable nobody would have accepted
that it would have been a terrible thing
we've just we've done it right I can't I
can't believe how incredible the
American people have been because they
went out and they really did this Chris
you know when you think they went out
and and they did what they had to do you
know there every once in a while a
country like Sweden will be thrown out
or Brazil now Brazil is having a hard
time because they you know they having a
hard time but Sweden the people in
Sweden did it running around shaking
hands and hugging and kissing each other
you know they're the bars are closed and
then the people are staying in the house
the Prime Minister's don't have to
doesn't have to say in Sweden stay in
your house the people stay there
automatically and you know they're using
that as an example but they've been hit
hard they've been hit hard but again
they're proud you call it automatic
I mean it's automatic distancing it's
automatic protection but places were
closed the bars were closed can't stand
at the bars you can't do certain things
you know now what we did was what we did
is a great tribute to this country but
if we lost so if we lose 65,000 people
it's so crazy to say it it's just so
horrible but it will lose 65,000 people
and instead of that going the other
route we would have lost a million or a
million and a half or 2 million it's
possible it's possible that you lost
more but could you imagine look how
horrible it is to lose 65 and then
multiply that times many many times that
would not be sustainable so I think with
all of that I want to just thank
everybody and I want to thank these
business folks are are just tremendously
talented people people have no idea how
talent that they are the job they do and
we're getting our way back and
getting our way back I think much faster
than people think and I think it's going
to be a much more a much more successful
launch than anybody would have thought I
really think next year's going to be a
tremendous year and I think the fourth
quarter is going to be Larry I think the
fourth quarter is going to be fantastic
I can feel it you know I can feel the
demand it's it's gonna be really
fantastic thank you very much everybody
thank you
[Applause]
you